hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I'm going to be introducing you to
my new best friend this is the ozobot
Evo
it's a social robot it says so right
here so what exactly does that mean well
this little guy is programmable you can
play games it's a toy but it's also a
learning tool
there's also a super cool little social
network so if you guys want to talk to
my bot my username is iJustine so all
you have to do is search for it and you
guys can find it and we can be friends
and send messages it's like the new cool
thing robot social networks I'm so into
it
spoiler alerts I've actually already
unboxed and been playing with one of
these little guys but the cool thing is
that you have more than one of your
brother or sister your family member has
one you guys can actually bring them
together and play with them but if you
aren't near each other of course you
could use the social network good enough
Jackie because I want to open this up
and show it to you guys because I've
been having so much fun with this one
just open us right up here I am obsessed
with the packaging like look how cute
this is everything is super organized
first thing you'll see here is some
little setup directions it's super
simple to set up we'll be getting into
this in a second in here this is a cute
little skin for your evil BOTS so you
can dress them up so they can look super
cute and inside here we've got his
little charging cable and also this cute
little carrying bag so able to carry
your little cord and your bot with you
wherever you go we have got some markers
these are the official ozobot markers
now with these you can do all kinds of
sorts of things you can program on paper
so by drawing different colors of
different shapes you're able to tell
your ozobot exactly what you want it to
do one Evo's off line you can create
your own play filled with markers or
paper and even use these short color
codes called ozo codes and then the bot
is released from his tiny little home
I'm gonna put on her little outfit just
like so and your on button is right here
oh she's ready to roll so in the
directions it says you turn it on and
then over here this is a nine piece
playing field it's got like a little
puzzle but it's basically the landscape
for your ozobot I wasn't ready put this
puzzle together we've got a little
puzzle together let's link up our ozobot
with our phone so basically you just
download the ozobot Evo assets you can
see here I already have mine set up you
just have to make an account here it is
I'm gonna keep this skin off of this
ones you guys will know the difference
between which bod is which set up
the second bot I think I'm gonna name it
mom so now I have two BOTS I have mom
and I just Evo now both of my bots are
lit up so inside the interface for your
Evo there's all kinds of things that you
can do you can make it make different
noises they have a bunch of preset ones
but you can also record your own sounds
so in the drive app I can control my
little Evo I can make her drive so this
is I just Evo she's driving I'm gonna
make it laughs nor can also adjust the
speed take a bit go super fast so as far
as customization goes you can also
customize the colors exactly the way
that you want them to be so you can
choose whichever lights you want and you
can choose the color from the color
picker so you can make it look however
you want and for Mom I'm gonna pick
these crazy lights I can also control
both BOTS at the same time which is
pretty cool
[Music]
so to put this whole playing field into
use you're gonna place your little bot
here and you're gonna press down until
the light turns white in place our bot
on the line and you will see it'll turn
red green red green and he's like yay
so with this piece of paper we're going
to be able to code our O's about to tell
what we wanted to do so much like the
puzzle can just be like yo go this way
go to the bot red green red he also has
obstacle avoidance too so if I were to
put my hand right in front of Evo it's
like I can't go any further
now I got snot and of course do you have
more than one bot I'm a just a basic
line they can both do the same thing
save it also program your ozobot egos
using a thing called ozo blockly so you
can do this online you can do it on your
iPad there's so many more advanced
block-based programming that you can do
on oza blockly you can change out Evo
response to color codes the play field
and so many other cool things there's so
many things even on the website that you
can download there's PDFs there's games
and there's so many more things that
people are programming and that the
ozobot community is creating but also is
extremely exciting is my sister has
knows a lot blesses hers and her iPad
say I'm going to show you how you can
add friends I'm gonna search for
iJustine which is my boat's name yes I'd
like to send you seen a friend request
and I'm going to accept her friend
request
so now her friends I can send her oh so
chats and O's oh jeez which is basically
like a bot emoji but I said hi that's
exactly what I said I'm gonna send her
something else
and as og and let's see my other message
so on the web there's all kinds of
little things that you can download on
your iPad or your mobile devices so
you're able to actually interact with
your ozobot on a digital device so in
this little game you are trying to help
your ozobot get from point A to point B
oh no I'm sorry I don't have trying I'm
trying I'm trying there's so many things
that you guys can do with this and I've
been having such a great time so I hope
that you guys enjoy these you guys want
to get more information about the ozobot
evo I'll put a link in the description
and also if you already have one
you guys can check out the website
results can learn all of the cool things
that you can still do with these all the
fun games you could down I'm sorry oh
sorry do you guys have any questions
feel free to ask them in the comments
below and hopefully I'll be able to
answer them for you I'll see you guys
later bye connecting connecting dots
that's it that's it so on this screen it
gives you a percentage of how charged
your air pods are and how charged the
charging dock is oops I closed it I
didn't mean to close it as soon as I
open it that popped up that's fast let's
take them out and this is going to be
the real test okay